welcome to another edition of beginner
breakdown amy host mike Hummer over the
weekend we had a very special tournament
the millionaire chess satellite with the
winner getting a free entry into the
millionaire chess tournament in October
in Las Vegas held by a Maurice Ashley
and Amy Lee and so the winner of the
event there were two priyadarshan Kanna
Pam and fellow international master
Ashwin jerem and priyadarshan I got him
and the arm again match which will be on
our YouTube channel
it should PI already be up there so
hopefully you guys checked it out it was
a lot of fun and our very own Mario rope
or had an excellent tournament he broke
even two and a half two and a half he
sacked a rook even in one of his games
against 1800 and 1810 eat his arm off
you were so mad about it right
and now his bank account and his chess
rating are both in the four digit mark
yeah good job
and also in the audience is a st. Louis
Chess Club staff member uh Danny Magoo
qey and he actually beat a chess master
knocking a back down to the expert
expert ranking but we're not going to
show you any of the any of the good
games from this we're gonna show you the
house games that's what everybody cares
about the house games so I get to play a
house game against Abby and this kid is
a noxious okay earlier the Friday action
quads he's picking at his hand and and
oh guess what my hands bleeding and it's
like come on and I'm supposed to be the
hero and save you alright so I wanted to
revenge massive revenge against this kid
so here we go I got the white pieces
it's the house game so I start out Eve
or he plays the French defense
alright so Knight c3 the Winter War
variation it's the best
and so now they play Knight f6 so now
he's got two guys coming down on my e
pawn so you can obviously just pin the
night okay
so he breaks the pen so now when we take
the night takes back with the bishop and
now we make us Bishop move a lot right
so we're feeling pretty good alright so
so now which pawn or even piece there's
only one well there's actually two I
guess if you count the rook but what is
the only other piece or pawn that's not
protected in this position for black
besides the rook well there's a lot of
choices ghazal only one thing's been
traded but but it's pretty obvious to
see this Jeep on is undefended so we
attack alright with the Queen so so I am
attacking the Jeep on so now black
enters the danger zone he castles right
into it he protects the Jeep on which is
true but he's having his King do it and
now the Jeep on is in up in okay so
obviously the Queen can't do it by
herself
so we have ideas like h4 h5 h6 but kind
of slow and by the time that happens so
you can just play g6 so we're going to
use our or our big pieces the minor
pieces to help out this attack here okay
so c5 he kind of ignores the attack so
it's fine so we could just capture it
now Bishop so look at blacks position
and the halfway mark here
he's got no pieces over there a lone
King so so now's the time to you know
start threatening checkmate huh bring
out the knight throw any checkmate in
this position with Queen h3 or Queen h5
or just lead to g6 so so what we'll
bring another guy in first so now black
plays the bad move right f6 here
okay so so when somebody plays f6 this
is when your eyes should get really big
in the chess game and be like okay now
I'm going to to try to export it usually
the easiest way to exploit a move like
f6 is to just capture it but in this
position we'll see that actually kind of
helps I'll be the black player out here
because you know now he's got his Queen
in the defense he's got a lot of people
coming down on f2 so we don't want to do
that cuz now he's got ideas like bump
which is a discovered attack on my Queen
see Bishop attacks and then you know
fork so I would really just help him out
so okay so
so let's thread a big check here and I
really wanted him you know you could go
you could play here here here but I kind
of wanted to induce him to play g6 now
because I was going to just sacrifice
and and there's no way he's going to be
able to protect this it's just it's just
impossible I'm gonna have Knight g6 here
and then he's gonna be in a lot of
trouble but he's like okay I'm Nick I'm
not gonna do that I'll play a h6 here so
now Queen up threatening a lot so now he
plays the move f5 so you just keep the
pressure on and he keeps creating all
these holes in his position so g4
there's no stopping yeah and now he
plays the move Queen e8 so I was kind of
banking he was going to play Queen to e8
cuz because I had noticed that it winds
a pond now notice that pawn takes f5
does it work in this position because
after Queen takes pawn takes or neg
hangs okay so we got to be looking for
all that stuff so so obviously if you
just take the Queen rook takes back pawn
takes and then if he takes here
we'll take so after pawn takes he plays
h6 so now I have a lot of different
moves in this position could try maybe
f6 maybe even work to g1 but you could
just take the pawn and just bank the
profit you know now I got more pawns
than you and there's nothing you can do
about it okay so now I start thinking
weird here like I should never even be
thinking like this so so I'm reminiscing
back to Jonathan trances a great gift
sacrifice for whatever reason so in this
position
maybe Castle that way is the best
because I'm not really afraid of this at
all you know not afraid okay so instead
I Castle this way and I'm giving up a
pawn but I think it's a trick but it's
really not so I take this pawn with my
knight and so now he's up a free night
and so when I played this Bishop check
one it doesn't even get a pawn
unfortunately and two it just so
basically I traded pawn for a pawn and a
bishop for a bishop and in the meantime
I drop tonight so I'm not looking very
good in this position huh alright but
you know life goes on you know I
miscalculated and I was too busy
thinking about trying to him fall for a
trap that wasn't a trap and neck good
but it look I still got this pawn he's a
passed pawn so we have to look on the
bright side of things okay so so knight
c6 that attacks it so I attack his pawn
because it doesn't look like I'm
actually gonna be able to hold this pawn
and so he's got a neat way to trade the
rooks
so there's a lot of different things you
can do here you protect the rook double
the rooks retreat the rook but the
easiest way is to just capture it even
though it's probably not a good idea to
capture stuff when you're down
it's almost forced to play there so now
when I play rook to d1 which move do you
think black should instantly do here you
should just give me a check because now
I have to play King to be one but he
doesn't do it he just brings his knight
back to c6 so I go back to d7 attacks
the pawn so let's see what he he ends up
playing here or actually I play our work
to d5 I really want to protect my pawn
so now rook e8 so c3 and now he plays
check but you might think well you know
he's up a piece what what what does it
really matter if you know he checks me
now or later oh well my King is really
gonna have to pick up the slack in this
position because I'm down a piece so I
have to make him somehow become a piece
and help out advancing this pawn so my
king is gonna have to become a warrior
in order for me to win because if he
just sin back on the back row my rook
and Knight and this one point or if
you're going to be able to break through
so I really need my King to get up there
as fast as possible and the fastest way
to move a king is diagonally as well see
okay so now so now he's got three guys
on too so so there's no way I can save
this pawn now so when you can't save you
know a piece or a pawn you must generate
an attack greater or equal to there so
so he plays so I play rook to d7 now
attacking the pawn and how do you think
he protects the
pawn I'll give you a hint he does it the
exact same way he he did it in the first
place okay so it worked once for him so
he's like okay I'll do it again
it's all right so I take he takes and
now I get my King rolling up the board
and and now he's he's in the game he's
in the game so so this was very tempting
in this position to trade Knight takes
pawn takes and that come up here notice
I can never actually even but then black
could play some max defense here and
just play Knight here and if I ever take
obviously take so I can't do that
if I get him gumming up here you know I
think he'll be I think he'll be okay
maybe maybe I want to go there but
bottom line is he'll be able he'll be
able to hold on here you should be able
to at least and I think I think he'll be
fine
so I decided not to not to capture
instead I play King to d5 just keep my
King running up the board so Bishop the
d8 King up he praised his King up and
this this is with with his moves like
Bishop to g5 and and then subsequently
King to g6 notice he's not getting his
pawns rolling because once he gets his
Jeep on an H pawn against my one lone
pawn rolling he'll get a queen and win
the game
so it plays King to f6 King up now he
finally plays the move g5 so now I've
got a I've got to get
get something going really quick or else
I'm going to be toast in in short order
so I play Nate here notice that if you
would take my night and would take back
and then I would win the game and
there's nothing he can do
okay so he doesn't trade he sees it
somehow so plays Bishop to e7 and I
can't trade the night here I would just
be a losing game okay so I gotta put my
Knights somewhere so I put on back on e
- you always want to keep your if you
don't know where to go especially try to
keep your knight in the center so it
keeps all your options open like I
didn't calculate anything after 92 I was
just like he's got to go somewhere if he
goes to be three or c2 got to keep them
in the center so now I can hop anywhere
alright so night up to e5 Chuck
obviously so I got to go get I got to go
get these pawns so a five and now once
again I keep playing for kind of tricks
okay so obviously King to a six that's
got to be the bright move but I can't
play King to b6 hoping that he plays a
bishop check and he does even though
that's the second-best move and and then
I play another bad move here King to b5
all right no King to c5 because I wanted
more in the central came to b5 is what I
should have played so when I play King
to c5 what move do you think black slams
here and he guesses from the audience
Knight to d3 check it's a fork
in a lot of trouble okay I just lost one
of my pawns so now I'm just down a pure
piece right now okay what you got to
still look on the bright side I got a
one pastor of that so I hope he turns
into a coin or else I'm gonna lose this
game all right so so Knight to g3 that's
good because it stops h5 here
all right so Bishop attacks the night
and the pawn and this is embarrassing I
got to go back to f1 so it's that
looking good for the home team right now
it's not looking good at all so
obviously in this position black should
just play h5 instead he plays King to f5
which is not a good move because it
allows my knight to move off of f1 with
Chuck and of course I am playing a 700
so everyone knows what the 700 does in
this position puts his king in a four
Keable position all right so so now I
get it
but am I really winning here the answer
is no no all right but he's bound to
screw up again so Knight to d5 get my
knight going so King takes and now I
play Knight to f6 once again preventing
h5 and temporarily postponing his pawn
to g4 if if he was really good in this
position he would have played the move
King to h3 followed by boomp boomp boomp
queen okay but instead he puts his a
king right in front of his furthest
passed pawn not recommended so now I
gotta get my pawn rolling so King up
again like there's no way this King is
ever gonna be able to stop that pawn so
if that's what he was thinking about it
was not good he wanted his King back on
h3 you know chaperoning the pawn to g1
all right so
gone up night there pawn up and he
really needs to move his King here but
instead he plays Knight to b6 and guess
what
Knights have the ability to fork each
other okay and then once he plays check
the game should be over but but you know
this hasn't been a Picasso or anything
so maybe I try to screw it up one more
time so so Queen so I give them big
check and and I think okay I don't have
to think anymore
my Queens on g1 I'm gonna stop thinking
you should never stop thinking in the
game of chess okay until your opponent
resigns
alright so so obviously in this position
okay it's white to move what move do I
have to play in this position
where's your queen h2 yeah excellent
Mario Queen h2 that way it's gonna be a
while before he can uh you can do
anything good instead I'm like up I'm
still on autopilot yeah and now I'm like
oh my god how did I screw this up
and so I would be I'm a little scared so
when you're scared you just got to give
him a check right still scared check and
now it's like oh my god so he's gonna
get a queen on the next move unless I do
what unless I pin the dude all right
so black has an easy draw here he can
just play his King back and we can just
do this for the end of time okay but
luckily but luckily I have about 30
seconds left on my clock at this point
this is a game 45 d5 but I was busy
doing a lot of other things during the
game like trying not to lose and so so
he plays he plays the very very dubious
h2 here all right
luckily I've been playing a lot of
bughouse lately especially with a
world-class player of Fabiano caravan oh
so you can see it all on YouTube but
anyhow luckily it was like well black
only has one legal move in this position
if it was his turn right and it would be
king the g1 if his King was on g1 and I
could place that Queen anywhere on the
board where would I want to put it so
luckily I had 30 seconds go and somehow
I found it with nine seconds to spare
so what move do you think is the winning
move in
position any other move probably loses
or at least draws
anybody got any guesses
Queeny for double exclam and all he can
do now is resign ooh checkmate game old
I was surprised that I saw all right so
that's the best play game but but you
know if you're down if you've done a
piece you got nothing to lose if you get
if you make your king of warrior and he
ends up getting checkmated well so--but
you know get him out there get him
fighting and hopefully he can do great
things all right so so now we got
another house game here
Jonathan strengths he has the black
pieces against crisp iron he was really
excited about playing Chris Brown
because I guess he gave some lessons to
Chris and now all of a sudden Chris
decide he wants to have lessons from
everybody not just Jonathan so he wanted
to show him like you should have been
given lessons from me the whole time so
the previous game Chris Byron actually
had you tried to do a comeback he ended
up skewer in a rook you know King ruck
and got a rook but here was just down so
much it didn't matter
so that's why he got the buy-in this
round for here so so let's check it out
here all right so Christopher starts out
efore Jonathan II five night at acts
upon knight c6 so so Jonathan just wants
to mix it up so he plays on f5 very
dangerous very dangerous so he just
takes the knight give them double pawns
protects the pawn there so now Jonathan
ads on attackers to e4
so pile on the defenders all right
Bishop to c5 h3 I don't know exactly
what he's trying to snag
just rally stop tonight from going to g4
and attacking f2 castling would have
been better but now he sees jonathan
castle so he can't wait the castle as
well so now he's trying to break it open
here King h8 obviously the reason he
played King h8 is because he didn't want
to be checked on c4 and then bye-bye
bishop so attacks the bishop Bishop
takes Queen takes Queen d8 redirecting
him over to the rock the King side there
tonight to c3 and so it looks like a
natural move for the night here and then
when he plays Knight to h5 he wants to
come in here and so nighty 2 stops it
Bishop e6 g4 alright so obviously not a
fan of g4 you never want to be pushing
your pawns in front of the King here
so Jonathan plays Bishop here yeah you
know he's strutting around thinking oh I
playing great meanwhile the kids brother
and sister are around and they're given
Christopher like thumbs up it's like
yeah you got him you got him right where
you want them so then he takes the punt
and then as soon as Jonathan gets back
he asked Jonathan did I fall for a trap
and it's like well and then Jonathan's
like we'll see and so let's see let's
see how it goes so so Queen takes the
pawn so now when they got a lot of
pressure on these nights here so what is
a good way well maybe it's not a good
way I take it all back I take it all
back
let's see let's see how white proceeds
here so so this Knight is in trouble the
pawns in trouble so guess who's gonna be
the defender alright the King
so obviously we want to pile on here so
so Jonathan's afraid of Knight to g3
here and that would be too so he takes
it takes it and now it's time to pile on
with work f6 do anything of course rook
to f8 so Queen gets out of the pin there
and so Rick to f8 so which piece do you
think we want to move if we're playing
with the white pieces the night right I
hope everybody said night all right so
Knight h2 is the most preferable filed
by night to e1 according to the computer
here all right
but instead he has dreams of back row
checkmate
not good so now obviously he takes the
knight and now Queen - huh how many
times have we seen this where people
mistakenly think this is checkmate it
would be checkmate if if he plays that
I'll admit it but does he have to play
that no no no so so obviously black has
a checkmate of his own it looks like
here can we calculate our checkmate for
black it should be like within a three
moves or so hopefully
maybe
let's see so yeah yeah
excellent doesn't matter where it goes
checkmate game oh right and we go
there's the replay oh oh
checkmate okay so so he was mistaken
what the checkmate was now I thought I
was going to give you guys a real treat
all right
I had a game from grandmaster uh Ken
West where he he accidentally uh thought
that he had rook c1 I work c8 checkmate
in in his game because he had but
unfortunately there was just too many
protectors of the seeing square
unfortunately the notation you know he's
a grandmaster you can't you can't be
playing all these good moves and keeping
a the correct score so believe it or not
I have a game from an actual Grandmaster
Grand Master Shimin off he's from the
Russian Federation plain all-american
Eric ting chenko alright so so eric has
the white pieces and he's very afraid as
we'll see in this game there's a thing
called giving somebody too much respect
so here we go
so II for c6 the Carroll can and this is
excellent how how black plays whenever
they play the advanced variation this is
definitely how you want to do you want
to just you we just want to attack them
attack them at the base here yeah h3 no
no reason for age three here and in this
position I would have played Bishop to
e3 because I know hey that's where
blacks Bishop wants to go okay but you
know h3 for whatever
alright so Knight f3 d6 now he plays a
super passive again you know pin the
night
well don't pin the net well pin the
night
I play Bishop d3 Bishop you to the neck
that good okay so takes takes check and
as we learned last week whenever you
play your Bishop the d2 you're doing
something wrong I mean that's not where
the bishop goes so he needs the black
one Knight to c3
alright so Bishop the d2 Queen b6 so
white gets castle here Knight up so
maybe you just want to put this guy to
the test
a3 maybe but King h1 it's like what's
the point of king h1 yeah so he's
putting up little no no resistance to
the Grandmaster so takes takes and now
Bishop to e4
so so notice notice this D pawn very
weak here he's got two attackers on it
white currently has two defenders right
but one is about the goat so what move
do we have to play in this position here
I can only think of one but it probably
won't even work because as soon as we
play rook here he's probably just gonna
zoom his knight in there wa f5 so he's
in a world of hurt so he let's see what
Eric actually does plate finally brings
us now at the c3 so take and now can you
believe that how Eric takes back dis
bishop he takes back with the horn just
adding insult to injury and so Queen
takes Queen takes Knight takes so now
this Knights attacking the bishop and
the pawn and well c2 really doesn't do
much
so it gives them a check though I guess
the Grandmaster check I guess see it's
feeling good so King to d8 King G - and
now now the Grandmaster really wants a
strike Knight
they're threatening a check threatening
the pawn
yeah he can't play this rook or else
then that c2 trick gets in so he's gotta
bring this rook and and so he plays a
six where is the worst spot here it can
put this LightSquared bishop I guess
there's a lot of bad spots but yeah yeah
it's pretty bad d7 is pretty bad c6 is
pretty bad but there's one square that's
just as bad as all three of those
squares anybody see it
what is White's worst move in this
position
well besides yay d7 rc6 where Oh
see boy yeah yeah yeah yeah c4 is pretty
bad too but just as bad as all of them
is d3 because obviously it gets the
night fork knife works are pretty cool
huh and he can't go on he can't go on he
was doomed from the start
and so I mean I mean when you when you
when you're a thousand points you know
lower rated than somebody right it just
go for it you have nothing to lose like
like avi he went for it against me you
know eventually Christopher Byron he was
up up a whole piece against Jonathan he
was defending and then all of a sudden
he had big glimmers of checkmate and now
when the best of all those guys Eric can
crush those guys when he had a chance to
play a 2,600 instead he went into full
full yeah I know I want to be
politically correct here full passive
mode let's say and uh and you just can't
do that cuz because you letting them
dictate the game they're gonna generate
their attack and and you're gonna lose
all your stuff and slowly but surely die
a slow bad death without willing watch
the show for it okay so so when you pair
it up against somebody just go for it
because because as you'll see unless
they're a grandmaster they're gonna make
mistakes okay so thank you all for
coming that was a the millionaire chess
satellite around